hallo leute ich erstmal wieder eure mal
fahne und willkommen zu einer neuen
folge wie schmeckt ne quatsch man ich
bin wieder einmal wandel willkommen
zurück zu einer neuen freude wie
schmeckt und ich habe euren tipp
angenommen bzw
ratschläge und habe ein neues wie
schmeckt z gemacht oh mein gott bin ich
aus der puste
nur weil ich gerade die fahne für zwei
sekunden hatte wir machen heute die bsb
begeben netz aus küss den frosch und das
ist ein anruf ja hallo mein laptop
klingelt weiter ich versteh ich laptop
ich angenommen
hallo lasst uns aber vorher noch einmal
über dieses disney meisterwerk küss den
frosch sprechen das ist nämlich eine
verfilmung von dem märchen froschkönig
es ist jetzt nicht wirklich die
verfilmung von dem märchen denn die
story ist ja auch ein bisschen anders
es geht in der geschichte um ein
wunderschönes afro amerikanisches
mädchen namens tiana die 1926 in new
orleans lebt collins new orleans new
orleans am from your dreams war glaubt
wie ich auf den film überhaupt gekommen
bin ist so ich war auf dem disney in
concert konzert in berlin
da hat halt ein orchester die disney
wieder gespielt und sänger haben das
noch mit gesungen das war wunderschön
und da habe ich die lieder von küss den
frosch gehört und war echt überrascht
weil ich dachte sie an echt cooler film
irgendwie und die musik war auch recht
gut und habe ich mich gewundert warum
das nicht so erfolgreich war also warum
das auch nicht so in aller munde war wie
jetzt zum beispiel frozen ja gut frozen
ist haltlose erholt sich disney bis
heute noch ein runter
diesen film herausgebracht haben bei die
noch jahre damit verdienen werden und
mit irgendwelchen spin-offs olaf haut
auf eine krasse party macht einfach
meinen zweiten teil wie wäre es damit
und habt ihr nicht so viel
zeitverschwendung mit diesem ganzen spin
offs aber er hat sich jeder france nach
hinten
bitte kommt bekommt ein zweiter teil
weiß es jemand bitte in die kommentare
und falls ihr euch wundert warum ich so
aussehen wie ich aussehe das liegt daran
dass ich mich an den 20er jahren
orientiert habe sieht man das nicht
ich denke schon aber wer oder was soll
ein baby sein wikipedia.de ist
internationaler oberbegriff für jede art
von fett gebacken
das obst fleisch gemüse oder gar keine
füllung inhalten kann so fett gebackenen
wissen wort so werden beispielsweise die
bekannten krapfen aus dem café du mont
in new orleans als wenigsten zeichnet
new orleans wen ist kräften wie machen
wir das spiel heißt also an sich fett
gebäck aber wir machen spezielle babys
aus new orleans 20 jahren am intro des
films durch die stadt laufen mit der
straßenbahn fahren fleißig zur arbeit
gehen sie arbeitete dukes kaffee das
sieht man draußen und das steht da drauf
und dran und da macht sie ihre
weltberühmten base und da benutzt die
puderzucker und honig mit imbiss man
wirklich wie sie - kocht das wissen wir
aber weil es ein normales
handelsübliches new orleans bin jedes
rezept ist wenn ich bin jesus ganz
falsch sage dann tut es mir leid und
wäre das richtige wort kennt und jetzt
die ganze zeit ohren krebs davon bekommt
dass ich das falsch sagen sorry sorry
wird es ausgesprochen
kapfenberg das klingt etwas polnisches
wenn ja was gibt's heute zuerst sind und
für unsere babys brauchen wir eine
packung trockenhefe ein cup kondensmilch
zweier einen halben kopf
nein einen teelöffel salz einen viertel
knapp einen viertel kaputt gehärtetes
pflanzenfett 67 cups mail und einer
halben körper
wir brauchen natürlich eine schüssel und
caps und mixer und sowas aber das ist ja
klar
los geht's zuerst nehmen wir einen
halben cup warmes wasser und fühlbare
trockenhefe hinzu nicht die packung und
ein teelöffel zucker kommt noch hinzu
der zucker hilft der hefe sich zu
entwickeln die bakterien ein bisschen
anzuregen jetzt brauchen wir einen cup
von unserer wunderschönen kondensmilch
ich habe kondensmilch noch nie zum
backen verwendet und das kommt jetzt in
unserer hilfe party mit dieser kamera
einstellung kann diese gerne eine
handschlag skills wieder am tag legen
wenn ich jetzt nicht immer noch so ein
überraschungs gesicht machen würde wäre
das richtig cool aussehen
die spanne jetzt brauchen wir noch einen
teelöffel salz und wir nicht wissen und
zu guter letzt noch ein halber cup sogar
ruhig können so barkasse mehr videos
machen und mary mac south längst getan
was hat man denn eigentlich in den
zwanziger jahren so viel musik gehört
spotify ist dein freund
jetzt wird es ein bisschen seltsam weil
ich soll ein cup wasser in die
mikrowelle packen
bis das wasser heiß ist und dann den
film kaputter rheinischen never dann
biste vorbei war wie sie wort herr bin
ja es reicht wasser in die schüssel und
schüssel in die mikrowelle dann nehmen
wir doch mal unsere bude und ein fähiger
ein fähiger
ich habe jetzt heißes wasser ich nenne
dieses kunstwerk butter im see jetzt
soll die bruder in dem zeug hier
schmelzen schmerzen schmilzt gut wunder
wunder dass pflanzenfett hat sich
aufgelöst ich bin begeistert
pflanzenfett wasser kommt jetzt in die
andere mischung sein okay nicht so und
verrühren er wiegt jetzt möchte ich
etwas ganz verrücktes ausprobieren und
zwar habe ich normales mehr gekauft und
glutenfreie mail ich wollte mal
ausprobieren ob man diese sache auch
glutenfrei machen kann und bei lidl gibt
es ganz günstiges glutenfreies mail
ja und da mal jetzt halb halt und dann
werden wir gucken ob das geht
bitte schön aller guten intoleranten da
draußen ja dann nehmen wir jetzt unser
mehl okay wir brauchen jetzt für jede
schüssel 3 cups 2 und 3 ich glaube
eigentlich soll man das so nach und nach
zu geben aber leute wir sind crazy
motherfuckers also das sieht schon mal
richtig nach einem guten tag aus weiß
ich wie ein guter tag aussehen sollte
aber ich glaube so sieht er aus jetzt
schauen wir ob es mit dem team frei mail
auch funktioniert das wär doch cool aus
erstes fazit zu dem guten freien mail
es ist nicht so schön wie die der
normale teig also der ist ein bisschen
fest da hab ich das gefühl der hat nicht
so dieses käfige hefeteig dinge wie
jetzt mit weizenmehl seht ihr hier ganz
schön der sicherheit so cremig trotzdem
müssen beide teile jetzt vier bis 24
stunden ruhen und da ich mich heute
nacht weiter backen möchte sehen wir uns
morgen wieder ihr seht mich gleich
wieder also gute nacht 24 stunden später
der teig ist fährt das ist unser bild
zeigt und das ist die glutenfreie
variante also der teig mit weizen ist
auf jeden fall schön groß geworden und
flüssig richtig gut aufgegangen
der hier na ja weil sie sehen könnte
durchaus eine kamera also könnt ihr
genau auf meine hände schauen was sich
jetzt mit dem teig
mache mir hat nämlich jemand gesagt dass
es schade ist dass man es nicht was so
gut erkennt ich nehme mir eure
kommentare zu herzen vielleicht packe
ich auch welche einfach ein und bringen
sie matthias schweighöfer den sehe ich
nämlich heute abend das wollte ich
einfach nur mal drop ich bin nämlich auf
der premiere von hot dog neuer film mit
ihm und til schweiger den sich auch
hallo mein name ist til schweiger und
ich bin schauspieler einmal mehr auf die
arbeitsfläche immer jetzt soviel tycoon
versuchten auszuweichen
so schlecht aus da fühlt sich gut an
wäre es wichtig fluffig also das könnte
hier sind die gluten bomben und jetzt
versuche ich mal das gleiche mit
glutenfreien brauchen wir wieder unser
messer
das frittieren
ich habe leider nicht mehr so viel öl
ich hoffe dass es nicht so schlimm ist
heiß also lasst uns das ausprobieren
o
das geht aber schnell ein kraut wie
präsenter denn je so jetzt versuchen wir
noch einmal kurz die glutenfreie
variante sie gehen auch ein bisschen auf
der street ich schon aufgegangen
die anderen sind bisschen flach geworden
ich bin da wirklich sehr gespannt ob es
dafür die glutenfreien leute da draußen
auch so eine variante gibt wenn es um
honig geht kommt für mich nur flotte
biene in frage flotte biene der honig
für die flotten bienen wie steht er ja
ganz lässig würde im teller macht ihn
nicht einfach so gut ich kann den teller
20 drehen aber mach einfach mal den
puderzucker darüber und jetzt stellen
uns natürlich wieder der alawitischen
frage wie schmecken die gs aus küss den
frosch läuft so das wasser nun zusammen
oh mein gott wenn ihr wirklich mal
jemanden eine überraschung machen wollt
macht diese dinge nicht euer ernst es
ist so lecker dass einfach soulfood das
essen für deine seele
es folgt nun die guten free variante
ohne ich drüber und puderzucker und nun
stellen wir uns der zweitwichtigsten
frage wie schmecken die bands aus küss
den frosch in einer glutenfreien
variante jay khan juli den intoleranten
people da draußen besser als gedacht
muss ich sagen es ist natürlich nicht
ganz damit zu vergleichen aber ist eine
gute alternative also okay wenn ich
irgendwann restaurant habt gibt es auf
jeden fall diese dinge ich hoffe
natürlich wie immer euch hat die folge
gefallen und wenn ja dann zeigt dass wir
mit einem daumen nach oben
das würde
sehr freuen und schreibt mir die
kommentare was ich dann vielleicht als
nächstes kochen sollte habt ihr doch
vielleicht schon eine idee und was hat
das mit diesen wunderschönen
fingernägeln aufstrich warum kann ich
nicht fingernagel sagen nebel
das seht ihr den nächsten video bauen
bis dahin tschüss ich las matthias
schweighöfer kein übrig